Uh we have Jeremy here for Ravanel from
NAS AI. And um
so he's um
kind of been always seeing graphs and
thinking graphs and only recently
discovered that it's an actual
technology and there's a there's a
there's an actual community that's been
kind of doing doing it and uh fully
embracing it, loving it, and now fully
come to the dark side or light side. We
had a bit of Star Wars already in the
previous thing. So um
um
I'm I'm really looking forward to
Jeremy's actually going to um be in both
panel discussions tomorrow. First, we're
going to review this track and go
through the questions and
um then we're also going to discuss um
about ontologies
very concretely. It's a real deep dive
into ontologies. So now you've already
got your intro to what that be something
about conceptual model, logical model,
physical model, top ontologies. You're
hearing a lot of words. We're
uh definitely diving deeper into that
tomorrow in the old word uh panel
discussion. But without further ado and
as we're putting up the slides up,
Jeremy, maybe you can start with
introducing yourself even more in depth.
Welcome.
Okay.
Yeah, that's fine.
No problem.
Hello everyone.
Are you all good? Okay.
Um
while the slides are putting up, um
yeah, so thank you for the introduction.
So I'm Jeremy Ravanel. I'm French. Um
I um grew up in uh
in um
Brittany in the western part of France.
I was a rebel kid connecting everything
to everything all the time not liking
how school was
taught, how everything was siloed, um
and I was really um passionate about uh
history and science and music and
connecting all the things together.
So
this is uh this talk I'm going to give
you um
I originally did it um in June for
European Union when they asked me to
come and speak about my
take the work that we're doing uh for
semantic interoperability.
So it's kind of a revisit of this.
Um going to talk about trust, about
interoperability, knowledge graph, ABI,
the project that we are uh carrying on
with my team for augmented business
intelligence. It's kind of a practical
alternative to what we call AGI, which
we believe is not really
so interesting uh for enterprise at
least. And um
for um
a take about impact and the future of
semantic AI. So as I said,
I'm uh
I'm a farm boy, grew up in countryside,
um really loved everything about uh
nature and everything. And so
what I did is mostly turned myself into
what I call data mercenary for C-level
where I was this guy doing cash flow
forecast for them. And um
how did I come from that world where I
was I was so everything siloed and I was
very frustrated to to this is is through
the the topic of cash flow. And I
discovered that cash was actually this
thing that connects everything together
in an enterprise from strategy to
marketing to sales to operation.
And this really fascinated me and I was
like, "Oh, this is the space that I want
to be in." I really like this idea of
how to connect everything back to
generating cash flow and making
forecasts. So when I started doing my
Excel spreadsheet, VBA, and PowerPoint
presentation, I ended up like,
"Okay, this is this is a topic. Like
this is hard to do. How can we do it
better? What technology can we use?
How can we make it better? How we can
make it less chaotic? Because it's the
that's really what I'm passionate about.
Like how to make things less chaotic." I
thought that
when I entered the corporate world, it
was limit embarrassing to see how messy
everything was. And as I really thought
myself
pretty much I I I think it's a bit
silly to not having this conception in
your head when you start um and you're a
freshman and you start working for an
organization. You believe that you're in
Minority Report. Everything is working
good. All the things are connected. But
no, it's not like that. So yeah, making
digital life less chaotic is probably
what I'm most passionate about.
And right now I'm lucky to bridge the
gap between different uh things. So with
NAS and the company we started a couple
of years ago,
um we started experimenting automating
financial dashboards uh because this is
the thing that I knew the most. But then
everything comes down to all the
business events that are connected to
the finance. And so you need to map
marketing, sales, all the stuff that I I
told you before. So right now I I
the work that we do is open source. You
can go to Jupiter-NAS/ABI.
There you go you're going to see the
repo. And I was lucky to be spotted by
uh the guys at uh University at Buffalo
that are uh developing BFO, the the the
upper level ontology that I was
mentioning.
And um
also
working So I'm working with them and
officially uh
will be uh nominated research associate
with them to explore how we can use um
ontologies to basically ground large
language model into a specific context
so we can retrieve facts,
but also use them for stochastic and
probabilistic stuff. Once we have the
facts, we want to explore and do
simulations on other other topics. So
this is a research paper that we are now
building together. I'm building this
universal data and AI platform, which is
our mission with the team. Uh ABI is one
of the main project that uh show this
university to want to build. And uh
recently also I um started a a work with
uh Forvis Mazars, an audit and
consulting firm that you may know about
that is uh is they're very interested
into how ontologies can become kind of
the configuration file of an AI system
for an organization. And so using this
um
three kind of connection like research,
platform, and and audit and consulting,
I feel very lucky because like I'm I'm
able to navigate between all those
fields and learn so much from different
perspectives. So
this is like uh the short presentation
about what um I do.
And um
yeah, talking about AI and um AI
development,
I I see a a lot of stuff that is really
embarrassing. So the the high-profile
errors uh um
if if you mess it up, it's going to be
bad. Bias and discrimination obviously
is one of the big problem of large
language model uh with their data set,
privacy, economic impact, the loss of
of trust that can go with this, and the
regulatory challenges. So
those are the five things that come top
to mind when you think about uh AI.
And also
this is a hot take and a bold take also,
but I think LLMs should never be
trusted.
Uh they are they should be part of a
bigger ecosystem always. So when people
are thinking about LLMs as just this
this uh compression of knowledge from
the whole
BS on the internet, if you can say that.
Like the
let's not be fooled.
Uh we need to pair it with our own uh
knowledge, our own language, whatever we
think is is good. So
in this graph, I tried to represent what
I think should be um the ecosystem we
navigate on to.
And uh it's basically about consumer
intent. I have a question. I'm a
C-level. I want to ask questions about
my business today.
Uh I go to an LLM that triggers a
command that goes to the knowledge
graph. And the knowledge graph
in this context paired with the LLM is
able to say, "I don't know."
Sounds stupid, but it's actually a good
thing when you are able to to say, "I
don't know."
And if it has the answer, it will tell
you. But if it doesn't have, you say, "I
don't know." So um
that's the power of ontologies, I think.
Uh so when you do that, you have the
green green line.
The green line is about like 99%
accuracy. I'm sure that I have the data.
Here it is. Check it out. But then you
go to another loop where if it doesn't
know, you want to be able to go into
some sort of similarity search. What is
uh kind of approximative to what you are
saying. That's the orange red line um
that that I'm talking about. So I'm
thinking in terms of accuracy. How
accurate can that be? How moderate
accurate? Like green, orange, red.
Um and that's that's one of the graph I
should update cuz I it's changed a
little bit our perspective, but it's
kind of always the same idea of green,
orange, red uh for for how much trust
you can get from that uh system.
And obviously you have the this blue
line, which is more about
accountability. Can I prove the source?
Can I go back to the source? Can I see
the the file, the CSV, whatever document
that has been used.
Um I I see I love music, so I think
things are dense between things
together. So we need to have there is a
subtle dance to ground AI.
Um it's about communication and
language accuracy collaboration.
And I think it's like um it's many parts
that you want to play together if you
want to make this work. This is mostly
the idea of this uh of this slide.
Um and as I said um
a little bit before, I believe also that
um LLMs have their own sort of knowledge
graph embedded in them, but we need to
pair it to what we have as knowledge as
an organization of any size. Could be
organization of one, yourself, all the
data that you have, organization of
many,
your your business, organization like
institutions, any kind of
organization can be having their own
knowledge and and Tony was talking about
the ontological core.
The need for data product this morning.
I also follow the same idea
that it needs to be also paired with
So the good thing with
it's kind of a balance thing.
Neural network which are the the
fundamentals behind the LLMs are more
about
generic information and your own
knowledge graph through ontologies would
be more about structured based based
foundation.
So
at the end of the day it's about this
yin yang, this equilibrium between two
forces that combine together kind of do
something great.
This is how we're thinking about it.
And other people think about it.
So
I don't know if you know about Palantir.
Maybe maybe you do.
Those guys have ontology at the center
of their platform.
So that should ring a bell to us all.
Because Palantir is a
I would say quite aggressive in their
positioning and the way they see the
world and the way they also don't use so
much open standards.
So that that could be
an opportunity for companies that just
want to use a tool, but also some kind
of a threat because if you don't own how
the knowledge is organized then what do
you own?
That's a big question.
So yeah, that's that's one thing that we
we follow very closely and we
are Amble way of doing our work is how
do you find an alternative to this? How
do you open source something that kind
of follow the same principles? And as
you can see it's it's quite interesting
the way they frame it. There is
analytics workflows integration
models, data, and ontology at the
center. So we also think around those
areas. If you look at our open source
repository
it's always organized with those
categories as well.
And that's how we stitch things
together.
There is also LangChain who started
talking about custom cognitive
architecture, which I think is another
word for
ontology engineering at some point and
that we also see that there is a balance
between
prompt engineering, which is like what
we all know on how to prompt an LLM, but
including this ontological engineering,
this custom cognitive architecture that
we need to build combined together to
input the LLM is is actually the way to
go. How we do we we discovered that is
that I started putting inside a prompt
in some large language model
a part of ontology
of prompt engineering like you are the
assistant for this task and then putting
inside the context window the ontology
compressed
and I saw the amazing results out of it.
I was like, "Okay, so this is how you
constrain the LLM to
a specific latent space."
And then you can start querying the
facts and actually rely on those and
have good accuracy.
Um
Yeah, so about our work and how we see
this. So we believe humans will stay top
of the pyramid. It's completely stupid I
think to think about like replacement of
humans by machines at some point. It's
like
sci-fi. So humans stay in the loop.
They have a personal AI assistant.
They have this personal AI assistant
knows their preferences.
It will be connected to a bunch of other
assistants that are more business
focused. That's what we call ABI for
augmented business intelligence.
Those can be the domain I told you about
before. So content, sales, marketing,
operations, finance, open data.
Those are the six ones that we are
focusing on right now, six uh
domains. I will I will connect that to
the concept of a flywheel that we have.
And then you have custom assistant,
which is the GPT's level right now. Like
what ChatGPT has been putting out
over this year. It's mostly like
basic information kind of assistant that
don't have the the ontologies or the
knowledge backbone that you need to
actually rely on them.
So and at the very base you have the
ways to connect to the data.
So
either you chat either you search. If
you know what you want you will search.
You will not chat. You will just put
this and expect to have the results
straight away. Not be funny to just talk
to something that you just want the
result.
And if you want to code you have the
lab. So we think also about chat,
search, lab as three main
medium to access the knowledge and
structure it structure the data.
Um
the way we think about the platform is
also at this T-shaped platform.
You have data engineering, data storage,
AI tooling, and you have verticals with
the personal AI assistant serving as a
bridge to connect to all the other
domains that I told you about
for revenue, content, growth, and
marketing, for cost, operation, finance,
and open data. And at some point you
have a data and AI product marketplace
that you can
fork out of those different things that
you may be able to monetize one day with
your with your company. So
that will bring you potentially more
bottom line and results for your for
your organization.
So it's about building capabilities and
building offerings. And if you think
about those two things right you may
have something that you could distribute
and use for your own organization, but
also for monetization.
And uh
the way also we we think about all of
that is uh
about a flywheel. So as I explained at
the beginning of the of the talk when
I'm thinking about cash flow I'm
thinking about how to predict cash flow,
but you need to connect it to all the
business events that are
to to this. So we have the this idea of
starting with open data
intelligence. So it's not very clear
here, but you have open data so you know
your market, you understand about
your market. You want to map resources
and events. Then you have content. This
understanding of the market will inform
your content. So you'll start having
ideas and publications.
Those are
those are the white dots, but they're
basically ontologies, small little
ontologies, small concept that you want
to connect together. So
resource event ideas publications
that will lead to interactions. Those
interactions will be about people and
organizations that will be potentially
generating opportunities and deals.
Those deals will create
conversations. Those conversations will
create projects. Those Those projects
will create tasks. Those tasks will
create assets. Those assets will be
about will be mapped into a contract.
Those contracts will be generating
transactions. Those transactions will be
accounted for in the ledger. Everything
is connected.
And that's the way we are building ABI.
It's like all those different concepts
connected into one big organization
system, OAS, organization AI system, or
something like that that you want to
have in your organization to really stay
in control of every bit of how your
operations are working. And I think it's
relating to quite a bit to the
ontological core that Tony was talking
about. It's really a similar kind of
idea.
So
then about the assistant cuz all those
ontologies you want to connect them to
AI assistants and you want those AI
assistants to connect to those
ontologies to give you answers.
So what we think about is really like
and this is the screenshot of the
platform.
Is essentially to be able to have all
this list of AI assistants that could be
uh
seeded
from the six big ones that we created.
And um
yeah, you have you have the idea I
think.
And it's about breaking down complexity.
Cuz when you break down like the the
ontology and the knowledge that you can
access to small little assistant
you can also have some sort of an
agentic workflow where you ask your
question to your personal AI assistant
is going to find the one that has the
little ontology you want to access and
then go to another one another one and
build the answer like this. So
it's another way of doing it than having
a big knowledge graph that you query.
Cuz right now it's quite hard. I don't
know how much of you have have
experience about that. It's quite hard
to
just load into one big graph database
the full spectrum of what you're doing.
So maybe by breaking it down into small
bits and having those agentic system
querying your your different stuff
you have better answer. And I say maybe,
but I kind of know that now. So it's
it's a good way of approaching the the
the thing.
And so for for the backbone of those
ontologies that you your assistants are
connected to,
we've been exploring different ways of
doing it and
we found out that BFO was really
interesting. Had very hard time modeling
time and space when I started thinking
about ontologies. It was very
complicated to think about how to do it.
And BFO is really cool for that.
If you go to ISO it's an ISO standard so
you can see the tree of BFO that has
those different special and temporal
areas. It's quite quite well done and
and now I'm lucky to work with Barry
Smith and his team because they also
found out that our work was interesting.
So we are now trying connect with them,
understand how they think about this
very closely, and it's it's been really
fantastic cuz
since we started adopting those upper
level upper level ontologies we've been
like accelerating a lot in the
production of ontologies. It's been
really really good to
to do. So you have BFO as top level, 34
nodes, very abstract, process, role,
disposition, object. Those are the high
stuff.
Then you have mid-level ontologies, we
call it mid-level, and they have more
concrete kind of
>> [snorts]
>> representation. So, an agent, an event,
an artifact,
a currency, those kind of things. And
then we have the domain ontologies we
were talking about that are connecting
the flywheel together.
And then the last bit is the application
or use case ontology right here
that are more about your tools, your
actual applications. So,
for the example of
the semantic web paper about the task
management, you will have in a business
context, you'll have
GitHub issues, task,
HubSpot or CRM activities, task,
calendar entries, also task. And all
those are connected to the domain
ontology that is task. But as a task is
also an event as it's also a process in
BFO. So, all those things connected
together makes a nice
tree of knowledge that you can query.
And when you feed that to an LLM and you
say like, "What are the task I need to
do today?" It will navigate this and be
able to give you
the full spectrum of what you think what
should be inside a task
for what you have to whatever you have
to do today.
So, I think this task example, when I
was rereading the paper of the semantic
web yesterday because I thought about
like we discussed about it with Larry,
that actually it's a good way of like
getting back to the roots, figuring out
how we can look at this in the new lens
of agent AI and
ontologies right now how they can be
leveraged.
So, yeah, that's that's what we we do.
Um
And how do we do it?
Well, with good old data mining,
data engineering, looking at the data,
figuring out how to map it to the
ontology. So, back to what you were
saying like
actual data engineering and data mining
work, curation, ontology mapping, graph
construction. And then the bit that you
you didn't mention in the presentation
was this assistant configuration that we
start like trying to figure out how to
do.
And yeah, it's been it's been a very
rewarding journey, and we use GitHub,
CI/CD, FastAPI, data product packaging
with the DProd also we're exploring now
to package all that together.
And um
it's it's cool. We all had it
15 hours a day for the past 9 12 months,
so it's kind of now grinding a little
bit and and getting the results that we
want for the for the use case. And um
the cool stuff is that
it's it's also open source, so we are
welcoming any contribution on that and
hoping that this could be a way to
kickstart the the work
um
that organization need to do anyway.
So, that's yeah, that's the idea.
And this is not very clear, so I'm not
going to spend so much time on it, but
it's basically the infrastructure. You
see on the very left the data services,
the the ABI repository as the second
block, the orchestration block, the
storage block, the API block, and then
at
this level you have the workspace, so
the place where the interface. Okay.
Um
that's the sneak peek of the platform.
You see the graph here,
but you you can explore the nodes, you
can explore time.
And then you have the AI assistant. So,
for this use case,
it's the LinkedIn profile that I
transform into my own ontology and that
kicks my personal AI assistant with my
skills, my experiences. So, already it
has the knowledge of my previous
experience
and can help me answer new questions
because of the knowledge that it has
about me. And that triggers the whole
thing about content, marketing, sales,
operation that
we are thinking about.
Um
And then for for closing this, I believe
it's more about it's about organization.
At first we started thinking about this
business, that's a business thing, but
it's more abstract than that. It's about
all kind of organization. It's about
whether you're an organization of one,
whether you are a
a family even, it's an organization,
a business is an organization, an
institution is an organization. So,
all those things need to somehow have
the same framework so that it can be
interoperable at some point. So, how
much of an abstraction can we build
is is really a question, but
personal AI can feed business AI. If we
expose part of our
likes, we can also get money maybe out
of it somehow, own our own stuff and
communicate it well rather than being
used and the data being used by others.
That can be a way. Personal can feed
institutional AI, like our learning
experiences. For example, if we all are
learning about ontologies, why not
institution getting it into the program
for the next material they want to teach
at the university? That's probably
something that you want to do.
A parenthesis about that, I've been
like when I discovered about ontologies,
I was like,
"Where was that before? Like, how come
did I not see it? How come did we not
teach that at school?"
So, I feel it's it's a good way to
explore. Um
Also, institutional needs to be
connected to business. The research done
at the institutional level should be
feeding business.
And yeah, it's all about the flywheel
again. So, business, we talked about it.
Personal can be about your level of
health, drive your education, your
education drive your finances, the
finances drive your relationship that
drives your content you're consuming and
the task you want to do.
It's just exploration here. It's just
random
thinking about that. The institutional
level should be about research, thinking
about infrastructure, engagement,
policy, decision, resources. You get the
idea. You have a flywheel of everything
should be connected, and we think if we
think about this,
we might find a way to have this
networks of networks
that can help everyone own their own
stuff
and then
connect everything together nicely. So,
3 minutes left. If you want, I can
answer questions or finish on this.
I hope you found it interesting.
Yeah cool.
Thank you.
3 minutes for you to talk.
But
so, thank you so much, and we'll
definitely also continue on the joint
topics in the track. Any questions at
this point?
Hi.
Thanks for the
>> Hi. Um I think you may have touched on
it
um
partway through
with your example of task management.
Yeah.
>> But
how how do you get traction with this?
Because there's been a lot of talk about
this top-level ontology and
it goes across the whole organization.
But if you're trying to
if you're trying to get people on board,
you need a non-trivial
but small example. Yes.
Um and
do you have an example of that?
Obviously task management
>> the the open source repo,
ABI, you go
it's about task. So, we we show GitHub
issues, CRM issues, all into the task.
And when you wake up in the morning, you
ask like, "What should I do today?" You
have the retrieval that says, "Oh,
product-wise,
sales-wise, this is what happened." One
of the biggest frustration in in an
organization that we saw that are doing
product is the sales guy come with the
new ideas all the time.
And then the product guys are like,
"What the hell should I do?"
So, this is one example, very concrete,
that we're working on in various
organization, and we are trying to think
about abstract What is the most abstract
stuff everyone has? This is one of the
big thing that they have
across different organization.
So, I hope it answers. But if you if you
can go to to the repo, I really
encourage you guys to check it out. You
can run it with your OpenAI API key, it
will kick out kick out the the project.
It's all the packaged.
Should be fairly easy to kick if you're
a technical person. And if you're not,
just I can present it to you. I'll send
you the gates.
Yeah.
Yeah. All right. Any other questions?
Yeah, you you mentioned uh
to the AI agency pass a compressed
ontology. Yeah.
Explain what that meant.
Is it
Yeah, the compressed part of the
ontology. Yeah, there there is different
techniques you want to do if you want to
experiment how to use ontologies with
LLMs. The first naive thinking is
take an ontology, put it into the
context window, put a prompt, see how it
responds.
That's what we did. And it it has been
very funny because the first iteration
didn't work, and then I started saying,
"This ontology is your law. Don't go out
of this ontology. If you don't know, say
I don't know." And prompting it a
certain way,
the thing worked pretty damn good. And
but it was too lengthy. There was like
the turtle file, so we started
compressing it to YAML with the same
logic of having uh you know, triples,
but compressed and so less verbose, it
was working even better. No more like
confusion. So, this is what I mean by
compression of the ontology. When you
use this kind of technique, you want to
reduce the number of tokens to the
minimum
to leave space for the answers to to
come.
So, that's one.
The second is um
if you want to actually query a bigger
amount of data because you can only do
so much with the context window, then
you need to go to just loading it into a
graph database, making the SPARQL query,
getting back, figuring out Andrea is
here like where is the data and then
querying it. Um we had a very
interesting talk together about that.
So there is there is a bunch of other
techniques you want to do if you want to
explore bigger set of data products than
the actual very naive but efficient
compression. So what we figured out is
like this um
first experience was good that maybe we
could infer that if we have all of that
in in different AI assistant it could
bring more accuracy cuz right now when
you do the other technique the you're
losing a little bit cuz you don't have
all the context. So it's about cracking
this in a different way and and right
now to be honest we didn't figure out
how to make it as accurate as when you
we do the injection into the the the
input of the of the context window. A
quick follow-up on that. So is there a
different way you have to build the
ontology with the AI system in mind? No.
>> No? Uh no actually not but uh the upper
level stuff very important cuz if you
talk about a task and you have the
mapping to um the task being an event
being a type of process then it's better
for the LLM to understand. It It It has
the
ability to um
reason better
uh than rather if you put just like this
is the ontology and no upper
connections.
Awesome. Thank you.
Any more?
I wondered if you could um
pontificate a bit about why you think
the LLM performs better when it has
access to something like BFO because
the these LLMs are working with language
they're adept now with their massive
context windows at
understanding the meaning of individual
words Yeah. tokens or or whatever um
granularity. Why would it be better at
understanding some very specific
symbol from BFO than an English word
like task which for which it's got a lot
of background. It's It's a very
interesting question. We are writing the
research paper with Buffalo University
for that
specifically.
Cuz we figured out it works but we don't
know actually what's going on. So the
thesis is
uh
it provides
a constrained latent space that is more
open than just have talking about task.
So if we say task and we say okay this
is task then the latent space that is
generated from that input question will
be regarding task only but if we relate
it to event and process then it opens up
a little bit more the latent space and
then the answer gets more interesting.
That's that's the main thesis but we
still need to
to make empirical evidence on that. We
don't have it.
Thank you so much Jeremy and thanks for
that question actually. Just to kind of
my five cents on that BFO question I
think it can be two things. It's just
giving a little bit more context to the
task word which is a strong signal. Um
and then the other one is it might be a
look might be having these models
actually being trained for BFO because
it's been used quite a lot in in these
like really big data players. So it can
be two options. I'll I look forward to
seeing that paper. Yeah I'd love to love
to see that. Yeah.
>> been trained on
the weights. The weights that they have
put into the the training that's what
you're referring to maybe. I think they
have weighted ontology quite a bit
depending on the different models. And
our friend that Letria
that is at the end at the entrance here
he made a
he made a study on the different models
and how good they perform at
understanding RDF XML and all those like
ontology related stuff.
The he figured out that Claude was
actually Claude was better than others
and so
what on earth could be the reason why
like except the weights that those guys
have put into the different things that
they've been training the model on. So
yeah.
Okay. Great discussion. We can continue
tomorrow also in the panel and we have
lunch now so enjoy your lunch and we'll
be back here at 2:00. So see you in an
hour. Thank you. Thank you so much.
Thank you. Appreciate it.